[Music]
Gouri for
my main goal is to get back
I needed to go back to my daughter
[Music]
I was working in Texas when Hurricane
Elmo was approaching Florida my
four-year-old daughter was in Miami when
I arrived to the airport
Billy why are you going right into Miami
I think everyone's trying to get out
from there
I was like my daughter's there I need to
get back to her
you could feel the tense atmosphere
there was just so much anxiety
desperation meridians attempt to
evacuate skies over Florida virtually
empty was an announcement saying that
flights had got cancelled to go into
Miami
I feel like my whole world just came
down
I just didn't know if I was gonna be
able to like make it certain time
[Music]
it's out of your control
I remember them calling my name and
they're like you know we've got your
last minute flight but you have to run
you have to go right now because they're
boarding
I was just so relieved
[Music]
that was like thank god I'm gonna be
able to go see my daughter
she's like the best thing has ever
happened to me
you
[Music]